kevin phillips author of the new book
the politics of rich and poor wealth and
the american electorate in the reagan
aftermath what's the point of your book
i think the point of the book is that
during the 1980s the people at the top
of the united states really got a lot
richer more so than any other part of
the country policy had a lot to do with
that the favoritism of tax policy
monetary policy deregulation and as a
result i think what we're primed for in
this country is a frustrated
middle-class who wondered sort of what
happened to them but really didn't know
who made out are going to start
understanding who made out and that
during the 1990s we're going to see
pressure to change some of the
redistribution that occurred during the
1980s so i think that is the the overall
message and interpretation of that book
on the back of your book you've got two
people who are quoted about what they
think of it let me read the first one
kevin phillips is America's premier
political analyst his new book the
politics of rich and poor will
revolutionize the way we think about
politics in the 90s just as his 1969
book the emerging Republican majority
had such an impact on the decade of the
70s former President Richard Nixon why
did you use that well former President
Nixon was it was kind enough to give me
a good quote and I thought it was a
quote that was very much to the point I
mean I think his sense is that what's
talked about in that book is something
that's going to be an important
political dynamic of the 1990s you cut
your teeth on Richard Nixon so to speak
when well I started working for Richard
Nixon and in 1968 in the 1968 campaign
doing political analysis and then went
into the administration but only for a
pretty short time and came out but I've
kept in touch with him particularly
during the Reagan years and he's been
kind enough to say nice things about
previous books prior to this one and we
have lengthy discussions from time to
time he says nice things about your book
and your book says the rich got richer
and the poor got poorer
does he think then of the Reagan
administration well I wouldn't want to
try to speculate what he thought of the
Reagan administration because he passes
up the opportunity to be born in any
assessment when he's asked he has
however said in in some interviews this
spring that while he didn't want to
criticize former President Reagan he
didn't agree with his evaluation of
government as is purely part of the
problem and not part of the solution and
then he Nixon back during the the late
1960s looking at the failure of liberal
programs still felt that you had to try
to do something for people and you had
to use government as a as a vehicle and
government is part of the answer so I
think he has has had some personal
descending attitudes towards things that
were done by Ronald Reagan what do you
think of Ronald Reagan well I think
Ronald Reagan was a hell of a man to be
able to become president of the United
States at 69 and stand tall for what he
believed then I think he served a lot of
useful purposes in his first
administration I think he represented a
number of directions the country had to
move in stronger foreign policy bringing
government under control whipping
inflation unfortunately I think in the
second Reagan administration and there
were elements of this in the first that
he went too far and that what we wound
up with after eight years of Ronald
Reagan was a foreign policy that it
started to be devalued under the whole
around Contra scandal an economy that
was a mountain of debt so I think he's
sort of outstayed his utility but I
think we needed a lot of what we got in
that first Reagan administration the sum
total the eight years I think has a lot
of troubling legacies what do you think
of George Bush I think George Bush is
somebody who's a supporting player for
the the Reagan era who was now stuck
with administering it doesn't have any
real sense of it I think George Bush is
what I think of is it tennyson
trust-fund republican he represents a
different type of outlook he certainly
would never have done a lot of the
things Reagan did
that were a little bit dubious because
Bush is so cautious but I think it's
going to be very difficult for him to
survive four years of having basically
to administer of the results of somebody
else's ideology I think we're starting
to see some stress on that already
the other quote in the back of your book
is from somebody on the other side of
the political spectrum Governor Mario
Cuomo Phillips says convincingly what
Democrats have not been bold enough to
say and Republicans won't admit we have
redistributed redistributed our wealth
from the poor and working middle class
to the rich we have compromised our
fiscal integrity and risk our world
position Phillips says that the people
will compel what the politicians have
failed to do I hope he's right every
American should read this book as a
Republican in the Nixon administration
does that make you nervous no it doesn't
make me nervous I think that what we
tried to be back twenty years ago and I
say we although I wasn't in the
administration long but my concept of
what sort of new majority middle
American republicanism was about was a
lot more attention to the average guy
than I think the average guy has
received in the during the 1980s and is
receiving now from George Bush and to
the extent that the Democrats want to
pick up the the banner of trying to
represent the average guy and a lot of
them heaven during the 1980s I think
that's a very useful thing I don't think
that American politics works well when
neither party is representing the
ordinary American and I think that
that's been the case during the 1980s
and if Mario Cuomo can help the
Democrats start representing what the
Democrats have always called the little
guy again as opposed to a bunch of
theorists and other people that just
want to go along with the White House
because they're scared and they don't
have any ideas if Cuomo can make the
Democrats represent that then more power
to him he hasn't totally proven that yet
though can he be elected president I
think Mario Cuomo can be elected
president if the economy turns down in
the last two years or this year of the
Bush administration if the Republicans
have a strong economy had a
in 1992 if they can keep the balls in
the air that long then I think the
answer is no mario cuomo can't be
elected but no democrat would be elected
in that circumstance I don't know if I
count right but 22 years ago I think you
wrote this book the emerging Republican
majority this was published by Arlington
House whatever happened to Arlington
hospital I don't really know I'm glad
they were there in 1968 but I couldn't
tell you their status today because this
book hold up I think it has my sense is
that the emerging Republican majority
emerged I mean there are people who
think that I wrote predicting and
absolutely top to bottom Republican
majority talking about the Alabama
Legislature in the New York City Council
what that book projected was that the
Republicans would dominate the
presidency pretty much for a generation
or more they have by the time George
Bush's term is up in January 1993 the
Republicans will have held the White
House for twenty of the previous twenty
four years that's basically what I was
writing about the national politics and
I think it's happened Watergate I have
to say had me feeling and it wouldn't
happen back in 1973 and 74 but it did in
the end this may not mean much but the
book that the emergency Republican
majority sold for 795 back in 1968 69
and the book that you put out now which
is about half the size sells for 1995 is
that saying well actually the inflation
has been more than that prices have at
least tripled since 1967 68 sure we've
had a lot of inflation there's no doubt
about it I think the inflation rate has
actually been worse than what the
official rates have said people who have
to buy movie tickets and children's
sneakers and lunch in fast-food places
and think for health insurance pay their
local taxes it's really gotten out of
him the middle class has been nibbled
and nibbled and nibbled but we have had
a lot of inflation what's happened to
your own views about politics and the
Republican Party's since you wrote your
first book in this new one well my sense
is that if you go back and you look at
the history of the Republican Party and
I don't think I sufficiently
created this back in 1967 or 68 but it's
taken power in some of the great cycles
of American history it's taken power for
broad-based reasons in 1860 with Lincoln
in the Civil War in 1896 when William
McKinley fought back the William
Jennings Bryan challenge and then in
1968 when the country was really in some
ways on the verge of disintegrating from
riots in the cities riots in the campus
a southern sectional movement led by
George Wallace and the Republican Party
has played a kind of nationalizing role
it's kept things together during these
particular periods but once it's been in
or 1012 more years than that what we see
is that it tends to I think get get too
close to upper bracket economics a kind
of capitalist heyday in it it does too
much for the people at the top and it
loses sight of the people at the bottom
and I think the 1980s have had a lot of
that reviews are mixed some people don't
like your book at all and one that I'm
looking at is from The Wall Street
Journal
it's a fellow by the name of David Brock
who is with the Heritage Foundation and
that was published on Thursday June 14th
did you have an overall view of mr.
Brock the Heritage Foundation and why
that he didn't like your book well I
have an overall I don't know mr. Brock
at all I've never heard of him but I
have an overall view of the Heritage
Foundation in the editorial page of The
Wall Street Journal and basically it's
they deserve each other I mean if
they're any people who've been involved
in sort of blueprinting the whole lays a
fare deregulate cut the taxes hands-off
view of the American economy during the
1980s it would be groups like the
Heritage Foundation and the editorial
page which I differentiate from the rest
of the Wall Street Journal which is
superb the editorial page is all these
yuppies in red suspenders who miss not
going to Morgan Stanley during the
heyday
and clumping so I think that these are
the people whose policies I guess the
book would be would be dead against so I
can't say that I'm particularly
surprised that they're critical I mean
from their standpoint I think they
should be now you write for The Wall
Street Journal still as a contributing
as part of their group of editors well
I'm a member of I guess you could call
it the political strategists or pundits
panel but they run in the back page of
The Wall Street Journal but what you
have to understand is the the internal
divisions within the Wall Street Journal
the editorial page and the the news
operations are totally separate and the
people that but write the reporters for
the newspaper are totally different
groups in The Wall Street Journal
editorial page and they don't share the
same views means pick out a paragraph of
course this very fact ensures mr.
Phillips enthusiastic notices from the
culture police all the more since his
Republican credentials are seen to
bestow a certain gravitas to analysis
that unfailing jibe unfailingly jibe
with prevailing left liberal prejudices
I didn't read that well but you can see
where he's upset well the other cultural
police that's that's an interesting
phrase where do you meet the cultural
police I mean there they had movies do
you see them going into a bookstore I
think I know what he means but I'm not
sure what he's talking about or what he
would regard as the I suppose of people
who dominate the media it's interesting
that George Gilder supply side economic
theorist
referred to his principal opponents
being the the elite of the information
society so I suppose the elite of the
information society are cousins of the
cultural police I mean there's someone
who graduated from what was a fairly
populist republicanism back years and
years ago I I have to look with some
amusement at all of this this is sort of
populist labels used by people it
wouldn't know a grassroot from a piece
of asphalt who-who hole up in a lot of
these sore
of rarefied think tanks and and media
operations themselves here in Washington
it's it's ironic when I wrote the
emerging Republican majority all those
years ago what the Democrats represented
were people who had taken over all these
Washington institutions and who had just
become totally remote from the average
American and they they really had never
met a payroll they'd been on the
government slots of think tanks that's
what conservatism is becoming producing
foundations and think tanks and
editorial rooms full of all these people
that have sit around and sucked
ideological thumbs for the last ten
years so it's an interesting development
but I think it's a sign of conservatism
sweetness he he strings together a bunch
of the phrases you use and let me read
that he says indeed all this book really
demonstrates is how much the author's
high-tone sensibilities were deeply
miffed by Darwinism and babbitt tree
boone pickens and ivan boesky stretch
limos and $300 cowboy boots champagne
and raspberries hustling middle-class
reagan age and right-wing economists
these are all in quote marks Rodeo Drive
Sutton Place and the Florida Gulf Coast
well those are all in there if you take
these nouns they're in the book they're
not paired the way that they're paired
they're they don't appear in the same
places they might be separated by 46
pages or nine paragraphs I mean it's
that sort of thing but I think I find
sort of amusing that's the sort of stuff
the Liberals did 20 25 years ago when
they were on the skids
those are skid marks one last thing here
from this this particular review such
images peper entire chapters filled with
nothing but lists lists of billionaires
and sent a million errors and dekha
million errors lists of Wall Street 100
in the largest golden parachute lists of
International Bank on and on he talks
about lists
I remember reading in the emerging
public lists 143 charts and you've done
almost the same thing in your new book
why all the charts well I think the
charts are critical to proving the point
there was one fella that
reviewed the politics of rich and poor
and he said that we're Mario Cuomo spoke
poetry what I did is I had some of the
style of an accountant and he's
referring to the number of charts now of
course the Conservatives love the charts
that were in the emerging Republican
majority and apparently they don't
particularly like these charts and I can
understand why if you're gonna prove the
point it doesn't do any good to simply
say something what makes sense is to go
in there and lay it out put down the
numbers to just put down the numbers
from a lot of different directions
there's a chart in there that shows that
how during the of the 1980s the the
Forbes 400 richest families roughly
tripled their net worth there are others
on who made the most money in Wall
Street how much the top partners in the
the most prosperous law firms made there
are lots and lots of charts and the
point is that by the time you get
through the charts you've got a picture
and in this particular case those
pictures I think are something you can't
possibly do with words so there's a
reason for them how rich are the rich
the rich are incredibly rich see that's
what's happened during the 1980s when I
started writing this I really didn't
have as full a sense at all I knew that
there was a major change that had come
but I really didn't have any sense of
how incredibly large it was I mean there
are if you take the number of
billionaire's in the United States
between the early 80s and 1989 the
number of billionaires went from
something like 7 or 8 up to 53 or 52 the
number of millionaires in the United
States climbed from about five or six
hundred thousand in 1980 up to 1.5
million by the end of the decade the
money made was absolutely enormous and
this is during the same time when the
median household income and the median
family income and things like that
adjusted for inflation stayed pretty
much the same I mean they went up but
they only went up by a little bit so
what you had was an incredible
you Asian were the people at the top
were getting the big gains in the
economy and that's why things like
Architectural Digest had a surging
circulation that's why they had to put
area codes on the Atlantic and Pacific
Ocean so that people could compile their
yachts that's what happened to the
United States during the 1980s why are
we so fascinated I say we meaning the
American people through the tabloids and
the magazines and newspapers with people
like Donald Trump
I haven't most ski you you know would
you know those kind of people what is it
about those kind of people that were
interested in well I think there are
certain periods of history where you can
identify first a sea change towards a
more conservative politics and economics
and that's sort of at the same time as
that starts to catch hold and as the
economy starts humming and the markets
start booming in entrepreneurial azzam
starts surging what you get is a
fascination among people with the people
who are part of this trend were the
people who are the entrepreneurs and the
fat cats and we saw this during the
1980s you saw that the decade began with
shows becoming right at the top of the
TV list like dynasty Dallas and Falcon
Crest that was sort of a pre Trump
mentality in itself that was preparing
people to watch the Donald Trump's and
people like them and we had a
fascination with that during the 1980s I
think that's curdling now but there's
just no doubt about it it was a mainstay
people admired glitz
they almost admired greed not quite but
they were fascinated by it
one of the things that you can see in
your first book the emerging Republican
majority and this book the new and the
politics of rich and poor is a constant
referrals to cycles where did you first
get this notion that cycles were worth
watching
well there's a sense among at least a
considerable minority of political
scientists and historians in the United
States that our politics in contrast to
those of most other countries have had a
very strong cyclic upon turn and they
really have if you go back at least I
think so because you can see that
in history and the year 1800 1828 1860
1896 and 1932 and then again in 1968 we
had the beginnings of periods during
which one party really dominated
American presidential politics they
might lose once or twice in in 20 or 30
years but essentially they dominated and
when they won one of these watershed
elections a lot of things changed and as
I read as a kid in school I I guess I
became pretty convinced to that and
during the 1960's I thought it was
happening again and when I was at law
school and after I got out of law school
I was busy pulling together information
and then after the 1966 elections I'd
gone down to Washington I was convinced
it was happening again and I started on
the book that became the emerging
Republican majority and I think that it
will be deemed to have happened again on
the national level now what kind of
unique is a country to be able to go
through these things and I think it's
because the United States first of all
has regularly scheduled elections in
contrast to a parliamentary regime when
you never know when they're going to
come so politicians can kind of build
things around elections and they've done
that in the United States the second
thing is that we've had these cycles I
think in part because they're regional
and we filled in the country and as
different parts of the country have been
settled you've created different
relationships between the prosperous
part which is usually the furthest part
East and the parts that are being
settled and then regionalism has played
a role so for all of these reasons I
think that cycles are debatable in the
United States but have a more legitimate
framework that in almost any other
country and I certainly would emphasize
them based on your cycle theory what's
next what's next I would think would be
a center to progressive
something-or-other reformist cycle
beginning in the 1990s back in 1968
where we began what has been twenty out
of twenty four years with the
Republicans and it may well continue in
1992 I was a little dubious that
that it would happen in the old way and
it didn't happen in the old way because
it didn't happen below the presidential
level nearly as much we still have much
more Democratic strength on the local
levels and even in Congress now that the
Democrats have got the Senate back so I
think what we'll see in the 1990s when
we start a new cycle as it were will be
something it's even more superficial and
unless fully rooted and that the media
make it less than is possible to have
the old deep-rooted cycle where things
change from the top down to the bottom
but I think what we'll see is that the
progressive reformist populist I don't
know quite what to call it I don't think
it'll want to call itself liberal which
is one word I I don't think they want to
use will we'll get back in and that will
see more demand for government more
concern for the people who've been left
out more concern for for building things
again in the United States as opposed to
finance taxes will go up there'll be
more regulation hopefully there'll be
some good things do was you write about
the cycles you go back and show that the
taxes were real high back in the 20s in
a row and you'd do better at this than I
can and real low and this thing just
keeps going up and down so if we're at
28 percent right now you suggest that's
gonna go back up to how high of insulin
well that's an interesting question the
the first income tax in the United
States was put on during the Civil War
and it was then taken off in the 1870s
as the whole populist crusade got
underway Congress passed a law setting
up an income tax again in 1894 but the
Supreme Court threw it out so we really
got our first full-fledged income tax
beginning right before World War one and
it got up to a rate in the 70s during
the 1920s it came down from 73 to 25
percent just kind of like what happened
in the 1980s when it came down to 70
percent to 28 percent but in the
meantime back during the New Deal under
Franklin D Roosevelt the top rate got up
to 91 percent so I think what we're
going to see is that rate goes back up
again but I wouldn't think it's going to
go up over 45 or 50 and the reason I
don't think that'll be the case is that
we're probably going to have to have
some consumption taxes
whether it's a much much increased
gasoline tax or some form of a
value-added tax or national sales tax
something like that and if we do I think
it'll it'll enable the top rate to be
kept at a level that's somewhere between
38 and 50 percent so I don't see much
likelihood at going back up to 70 or 90
or anything like that but I do think we
will not see the 28 percent rate very
much longer
who in history and and both recent
history and American history or world
history do you admire the most and
politicians mostly well it's hard to say
because I guess I've been too involved
in politics during a period where
disillusionment and politics sort of
went together whether it was yet or
Watergate or Carter Reagan iran-contra
now read my lips and flag desecration
I'm not too impressed it's a very hard
question for me to answer I'm not sure
I'm a good one to even try you have a
favorite president in the 20th century
well of course I worked for Nixon there
are lots of ways I think Nixon could
have been the dominant president of the
post-world War two ERA he muffs some of
it and other people helped take away
from what he did do so I don't think we
can put him up for that role I think he
was probably in many ways of the
brightest but I know I'm not in the game
of singling out who my my great heroes
are people I admire are if you're so
much in the business of cycles in
history it gets pretty difficult because
you tend to evaluate them in ways that
don't deal with them as people as
historical forces as people who rode
waves as creators of of movements and
and that's really not the yardstick for
evaluating people one who has to be
identified in the twentieth century of
course is Franklin D Roosevelt there's
no way around that more than probably
anybody else the cyclic Oh evaluation
gives you an awful lot of the ones that
history you know that's an interesting
overlap I mean Thomas Jefferson and
you Jackson Abraham Lincoln FDR maybe in
a sense Washington and those are the
cyclic all people it sort of suggests
that when you're on top of one of the
cycles and you represent the beginning
of something that wins and has a great
historical effect it sort of builds a
presence for you historically I think
that has been the record I'd certainly
put all other people whose names I just
mentioned right at the top of any list
of American presidents you ever find
yourself when you read either
politicians or columnist quoting history
saying there they go again there's
another historical figure they just keep
trotting out whenever it serves their
purpose and then in fact they really
weren't that great or maybe a better way
to ask it who's the most overrated
person in history that you keep reading
about well if I were to go through that
in a sense one I'd pick would be Woodrow
Wilson because I think Woodrow Wilson
was naive and Woodrow Wilson was taken
to the cleaners on the international
stage he gets an enormous amount of
credit for being a man of peace and
global foresight as it were but yet with
what he was involved in he wasn't
particularly successful so there would
be one what about world his I want to
ask you about Winston Churchill and I
know this isn't fair to you because you
haven't heard the other interviews but
for some reason either we've started
talking about Winston Churchill here and
from both sides Christopher Hitchens
says he was not nearly what Americans
think he was and cap Weinberger writes
in his book that he was everything to
him and he'll be seen on book notes in a
couple of weeks
where does Winston Churchill fit in
you're in your mind as a world figure
well my sense is that while Winston
Churchill had a number of the weaknesses
of any politician and of his class which
was seen pretty vividly in 1945-46 when
he had some difficulties with
readjusting Britain to its different
circumstances after the war that by any
serious historical yardstick he was a
very very strong and dominant and major
historical figure
I mean beginning with his emergence on
the scene during even
the the Boer War when he was captured in
South African he escaped and he became a
front-page figure in the UK after that
and succeeded in winning a parliamentary
seat out of Oldham I guess it would have
been maybe 1901 1903 and when did he
leave the the prime ministership fifty
years later I mean this is a man that
whatever anybody might say to derogate
some of his particular circumstances or
or issue positions he marched across
fifty years of British history like the
band of the Grenadier Guards and I don't
see how you can take that away from them
you mentioned the cycles and how
difficult it is to look at individuals
the individuals matter in politics
anymore well I think they do I mean I
have the sense in the United States
right now that we have a set of failures
on the part of the Republicans and
Democrats and potential historical
convergences of great issues ready to be
laid out of understanding by the
American public waiting to be recognized
by politicians who are less than the
people they serve and I think what we
need is somebody who can rise to that
and somebody who can can stand up and
lay these things out and who's good
enough to do it so I think individuals
matter enormous ly right now and I think
we're paying the price for the fact that
I wouldn't like to say we have
third-rate individuals but I think
historically is very fair to say they're
almost all second-rate and what we need
is somebody who's not you mentioned also
that and I won't put this in the context
but you can about the media and how it's
difficult today because the media is
doing what to mean it you went on to and
indicate the media was messing up the
normal cycle well I wouldn't say messing
up but I think what you had the
evolution of a cyclic or pattern is I
think we've had it really began in the
United States because the United States
itself began pretty much in the period
of the Industrial Revolution in the
period where you had the the move away
from what had been an aristocratic
politics into a democratic politics
where elections became more and more in
poor
and more and more people participated
and electorates were mobilized and
parties came to the fore as opposed to
factions and as a result the earlier
cycles in this whole pattern from the
1800's early 1800s up through Franklin D
Roosevelt and the New Deal what you saw
when politics realigned it was pretty
much a top-to-bottom phenomenon because
the the role of the party was strong
enough that it became a major force I
think in the cycle we've had since 1968
one of the reasons why you couldn't have
a more substantial realignment is first
that the the media were pre-empting in
many ways the role of the party is an
information distributor government
bureaucracies were taking over the old
role of the party providing turkeys of
Thanksgiving or helping people who are
unemployed and then last but not least
the whole role of the media being so
prominent in shaping people's views
every night every day they had the
ability to speed up the process that the
the whole process of evolving issues and
changing attitudes could be condensed
and exacerbated and pulled away from the
actual old structures and becoming much
more free-floating and I think that's
what we've seen i I don't imagine that
we can go back to a 32 or 36 years cycle
in American politics as a matter of fact
the one we're in may be the last that
even approximates that and what we get
beginning in the 1990s may be a lot less
rooted and a lot more free-floating when
you wrote the emerging Republican
majority in 1968 there were only roughly
four television channels in most towns
president could say I want time and get
it on you know in primetime now the
average is 30-some it'll just keep
growing more and more and you've got 70%
of American homes have VCRs 60% of them
have cable television does that gonna
make it more difficult for a politician
in the future to get the attention of
the American people to govern I think it
may make it more difficult for a
national leader to harness public
opinion either as a candidate or as a
president when he's
office it should promote a balkanization
of the electorate and of power elites on
the other hand it certainly promotes the
ability of people to take off to launch
themselves as representatives of other
segments of the communications world or
of the people at watch a particular
medium or or of different interest
groups so I think it probably increases
the ability of politicians to function
in one way and then decreases their
ability to provide another function
we'll have to see how it balances out
because of this change is there a
different kind of person that's going to
be elected in the future after George
Bush well if you go back it's always
it's been tempting for people at
different points in history to say we're
going to see different types of
politicians and the funny thing is
looking back historically you don't
really think that because people and
their personalities and their desires
and their weaknesses tend to be the same
but it is true that there are certain
junctures in history where the way
politics behaves in some of the
weaknesses of it are very much
influenced by the media whether it's the
rise of Hitler using radio or whether
it's the actually very substantial
modernization of politics in the second
quarter of the 19th century because of
all the changes in communications from
the Telegraph to the railroads so it
always does make a difference I don't
see that it changes the type of people
historically but we may well see within
the timeframe of a decade or looking
back at a quarter of a century the
ability to say well certain types of
people rose who never would have risen
before and you can say Ronald Reagan was
a media president he never could have
come prior to the the age of the media
I'm not so sure because people have have
risen in politics who were pamphleteers
200 years ago or for that matter 2,000
years ago was just a question of a
medium of the era when I show the
audience the book it's politics of rich
and poor by kevin phillips it's in your
bookstores and it's about checking about
250 pages long roughly a lot of lot of
charts earlier I read a Wall Street
Journal
review in which the gentleman suggested
that you were going to be the darling of
the culture police and also of the
liberal media here is a very positive
review that was out this week in Time
magazine along with a looks like a fresh
picture of you and this does it worry
you that he predicted that the liberal
media would like it and then here is a
Time magazine saying they do like it and
is this a liberal publication well it's
an interesting question whether it's a
liberal publication I'm certainly
pleased that they like it I mean as as
politicians have said it's always better
when people for you than when they're
against you it helps and as someone who
was attacked by all the Liberals 29
years ago and I got my my cheer from the
Conservatives at that point I'm not so
sure you don't do better with a media
when you're getting more from the
Liberals but I would suspect everything
being equal but the the greater
preference for the message in there is
is on the part of quote-unquote liberals
but I also think that it would be a
mistake to figure that that's the basic
source of the the rise or fall of the
message of this book is going to come
from middle America and middle America
may not be as conservative as it was
three or four years ago but it's not
liberal and the ultimate I guess
decision on on a book or on ideas in
this system of ours usually pretty much
come from how the average American
reacts to it I don't think it would do
me a lot of good if the average fella
thought that this book was a lot of hot
air and the New Republic thought it was
terrific
I mean frankly I'd rather have the
average guy and not the New Republic
this is again a small point man I tried
to see some connection the books called
the politics of the rich and poor and
you had a chapter or at least a take out
and
this last Sunday's New York Times
magazine and they titled it something I
couldn't find in your book Reagan's
America a capital offense what was this
article and where do they get this title
well as the people that handle the New
York Times magazine processes will say
the the author gets to have a fair say
in any modification made in text in
other words when you excerpt a book you
take it in chunks and you've got a blend
paragraphs and you know we have an
epilogue in there that wasn't from the
book but I don't have control over
headlines or squibs so in other words
they're free to come up with a different
title and Reagan's America a capital
offense that's intended I think by the
people who wrote it which which wasn't
me to be a play on capital and the sense
of capital and the financial and I don't
really have much problem with that
because I think there was a lot of
financial mismanagement in the sense do
I think that the Reagan administration
was a capital offense in the sense of a
an offensive large magnitude ii
administration I have a lot of problems
with but I voted for Ronald Reagan twice
so if I'd been asked about that title
which I was not I would preferred
something else you are often labeled by
people in the media a lot of different
ways what is the label that you would
most like to have people put on you at
this stage in your life well I'm not
sure there was some question for example
on the part of the people at the Times
how I should be referred to conservative
or Republican or both and what they did
is they ran a check on whether it was
they just used the New York Times that I
used Nexus so they they wanted to get a
sense of how I'd been referred to in the
media for the last ten years and there
were there were hundreds of things that
they could take and the predominant
reference was conservative and was
Republican I don't have a problem with
that it's probably a problem for some of
the people who represent the current
flavor of both republicanism and
conservatism
but I guess I would say at this point
it's probably fairer to called me author
and commentator or political analyst or
something and maybe not to stress the
the ideology or the party that much but
I don't have a problem if somebody puts
it in reason I ask that is that so many
times people are labeled and in this
business that you're in and a lot of
people have find fault with that and if
somebody calls you a Republican
political analyst does that make you mad
the only problem I have with that is if
it's interpreted to mean that I analyze
things for the Republican Party which I
certainly don't do but I'm a registered
Republican on the books of whatever
precinct it is in Montgomery County
Maryland so technically speaking that's
correct to say I'm a Republican
political analyst I just have no
connection whatever with a Republican
Party this seems like an obvious
question but why do you write books well
sometimes I like it and sometimes I
don't I'm just in the process of
obviously having finished this and
starting at the stage of talking about
it and publicizing it and so forth and
it was a tiring effort as they are as
you more tiring as you get older I think
so I'm always tired of it after I finish
but I come back to doing it because as
Richard Nixon said in his most recent
book there's nothing that can substitute
for a book in clarifying and sorting out
your own ideas and putting them down and
then moving on to something else and he
said in that book that each time he's
done one he said it would be his last
and I can remember actually him telling
me this is going to be his last this
one's gonna be his last and it wasn't
and I'm sure this isn't my last I mean
if you write and if you you think and
you do this stuff there's something
fulfilling about it how many books have
you written depending on the count you
use I guess in terms of book books this
would be number five and what else are
you doing besides writing books well I
do a lot of different things I
- newsletters which I had itand
published one is called the American
political report which has been around
for almost 20 years now which is on
politics and political economics in
elections and the second which is now 11
years old is called the business in
public affairs fortnightly which is on
business government relations corporate
External Relations sort of business and
everything that affects it from the
outside and I'm a commentator for number
of different media and I've been a
consultant I go around and you have a
lot of speeches and talks for one of the
big investment firms so I stay very busy
the other media national public radio
you still do that roundtable political
analysis you still do work for CBS CBS
that's right I'm a commentator for CBS
spectrum which is their network radio
and at the 84 and 88 Democratic and
Republican conventions I was a
commentator for CBS television why did
you give up writing a column I really
got sick of the column it's called
feeding the monster and the monster had
to appear three times a week and I had
was willing to entertain the possibility
of once a week but three times a week
was a horrible experience and you find
yourself you'll produce one out of four
or five that you think is really good
and out of the other four or five two or
three will be okay but but nothing much
I know there's no fees gonna be one
that's a real turkey that you whip out
in 36 minutes when you are late for
lunch now there are people that are
perhaps more into commentating than I am
the whole notion of going and
interviewing these politicians that I
regard as you know one notch above a
melted Hershey bar that didn't appeal to
me reporters like to do that I basically
am interested in things that don't
involve actually sitting and asking
these guys so they tell you something
you know isn't true and you go write
about it anyway so I wanted to get out
of that and I wanted to get to something
whereby I would write only in terms of a
column type thing
I would write only 2030 times a year and
then I get to write something was large
enough to be a think piece and I do that
now I do about 12 to 15 a year for the
Los Angeles Times big ones that are like
twelve to fifteen hundred words and then
usually anywhere from two or three to
five or six or eight others works out
very nicely I haven't had a moment's
twinge about not being a columnist and
when I've been asked did I want to go
back into it I've said no where'd you
grow up New York City where'd you go to
school I went to the Bronx High School
of Science to Colgate University the
University of Edinburgh and the Harvard
Law School would you mind if either do
well my mother was a housewife like I
guess most of our mothers were back then
in the 40s and 50s and my father started
as a New York state government civil
servant moved up to become a
commissioner and I suppose a a little
bit of a politician but he never thought
of himself as dying
why did you get interested in coming to
Washington well the first thing I wanted
to be back in the middle of the 50s was
actually to go to West Point and I had
worked for my congressman as a as a
teenage campaigner and I guess I could
have had the appointment but it began to
become clear to me that there was a long
time between going to West Point and
being a general and I didn't think I'd
make that good a participant in the
intervening stages so I after the 1956
campaign when I started to enjoy
politics I forgot about that
and I guess I've had it in mind in one
way or another to come to Washington by
the late 50s which is what I did that's
why I went to law school not to practice
law which I never have but lay the
groundwork for politics when you came
here who did you work for and how long
did you spend there well I I got out of
Harvard Law School in June of 1964 and
was asked I guess maybe about six weeks
later to be the administrative assistant
to the Republican congressman from my
district whose name was Congressman Paul
Fino and I worked for him in in New York
City and then came down to Washington I
guess
December 64 January at 65 right in time
for the whole Great Society of Lyndon
Johnson and I was working for phyno and
enjoying being in Washington and being
on Capitol Hill and then after the 1966
elections I got the idea that the whole
Republican era that I had been sort of
reading about thinking about mapping as
a kid drawing maps of voting patterns I
thought that was gonna come to pass so I
started writing the emerging Republican
majority not under that title I didn't
know what the title would be probably in
November or December of 1966 and then I
moved in 1968 I took the book and I got
a job doing the sort of political
district-by-district
voting history poll analysis for the
Nixon campaign and that's how I went
into the Republican campaign and
administration and met Nixon has there
ever been a time in the last 20 years or
a little longer than that where you've
been excited about what's been happening
in government here in Washington not
very often that's the whole problem I
mean if you go back and you take my
political generation at the ripe old age
of just 49 I've been in politics for a
long time in the sense of in it or
observing it and I came down here and
let's say December of 1964 after one had
been a bad period with a Kennedy
assassination heading into the whole
Vietnam era with with more
assassinations than when we were or of
course happy after the 68 election but
that happiness didn't last you could see
was an embattled administration
demonstrations everywhere the mall was
an armed camp the country was divided
then watergate came and then we had
carter and that was i think republicans
in a small way enjoyed the
disillusionment of the democrats it was
just as embarrassed then as republicans
had been during Watergate and Democrats
in been during Johnson I think it's been
a disillusioning quarter of a century I
don't think it's been a quarter of a
century and what she's saying my god
weren't these marvelous men and Marv
was times exciting in a sense yes but
not the period during which America put
its best people or its best foot forward
let me read you a little bit from your
book that's in the foreword that
Washington should seem irrelevant to the
average American - a sinkhole to be
forgotten when the fish are biting or a
good movie is on television - means that
Republicans can keep the White House
until disillusionment can no longer be
avoided most Americans think this place
is a sinkhole I think they do and I also
think they think their state capitals
are by and large sinkholes I mean I
suspect that if you took a poll in in
California in Sacramento it wouldn't get
rave notices if you took a poll in
Florida on Tallahassee it wouldn't if
you took a poll in Pennsylvania in
Harrisburg and so on and it's clear that
Americans don't think Washington does
very much
it's a cynical set of situations by
which I think the Republicans the more
Americans believe that government can't
do anything the less they will demand
out of Washington the less they demand
out of Washington the more it squares
with Republican ideology of not doing
very much now as somebody who's a
Republican any students go back to a
different portion of this whole
Republican period I don't agree with
that I think the Republicans that this
whole business with flag desecration
issues and it's pornography much as I
think that that exhibition that Jesse
Helms is protested about and then the
NEA situation doesn't deserve federal
funding it's clear to me that the these
issues that are being trumped up or at
least is my feeling that these issues
that are being trumped up now are
evasions of the larger national
challenges and I think that the
Washington has got more of a role
ideally than Washington is playing
Washington has got to be the rallying
point for putting this country back in a
more effective set of policies and
outlooks and whether you're Republican
or Democrat I think you've got to take
some of that view and I think it's a
great weakness of the present
administration but they don't want to
develop that that they alternate between
pushing it back to the states and
we don't have any money to do it here
where there's a will there's away I
don't think they have the will in the
world of politics and elections where do
you put money as in the important
importance level in the economy is it
everything you mean money in the sense
of its role in politics or money as an
issue for the average American or both
well I guess is that can there be a
charismatic politician who can win with
straight charisma no matter what the
economy is or is it all controlled in
your cycle theory by the economy
well my cycle theory involves a lot of
things that aren't hard economic one
Nixon one in 1968 I would say that
culture and patriotic issues were much
more than the economy which wasn't in
bad shape in 1968 partly because of the
war
I think economics is is often a dominant
force but by no means always as much or
more of American political history has
been a function of culture and
patriotism as use of economics and they
weave together and sometimes they go
together and sometimes they contradict
each other in the early stages back in
the Nixon years and probably even into
the early Reagan years Democrats would
lead the Republicans in terms of being
trusted to help the middle class or keep
the economy going but the Republicans
were deemed to be much better on keeping
America strong or preserving this or
that value or fighting crime or things
like that so it's a mix but I would say
the really troublesome angle at this
point is that politics in the United
States now has become a matter of money
in terms of its technical aspects of
winning elections of being able to keep
yourself in power it's so much a
question of money that people who ought
to be having ideas are spending their
time raising money people who should be
going to a committee hearings are going
to fundraiser people who should be
listening to their constituents are
listening to their contributors and the
net result is a politics that reflects
all that it doesn't reflect ideas it
doesn't reflect the the values of the
grassroots they talk about values but
why are fewer and fewer people bothering
to vote because their values are
represented no because their value
aren't representing the last time it was
down as low as it is now is what 1924 or
something like that yeah I would say
that probably it was right after women
had gotten the vote and women were sort
of slow to move into the same level of
participation as men were and it would
have been in 1924 right in the end well
then with no extenuating circumstances
is this the lowest percentage of voters
ever 50 percent on a national election
no because you go back into the 20s but
if you go back before the 20s it
probably is because say in nineteen in
1824 1820 or 1828 you were just starting
to have the enfranchisement of ordinary
people right after the Revolution you
might not have more than ten twelve
fifteen percent of the the adult males
allowed to vote in a place like
Connecticut or New Jersey simply because
they didn't meet the property
qualification it's only by the 1830s
that you're getting past any of that and
by the time you did get into the 1830s
and 1840s the turnout was a lot higher
than that is now so in terms of the
modern United States where everybody can
vote this is about as low as it gets
he's gonna keep going I don't think so
because it's just inconceivable to me
that the politicians can maintain sort
of the present level of
non-responsiveness of intellectual
bankruptcy of not being willing to to
raise issues because they can't afford
to because of their contributors I think
somebody's gonna move around that
somebody's going to stand up and
somebody's gonna raise those issues and
I think when somebody does if he can
measure up say he or she but it's much
more likely to be a male politician then
I think you'll see turnout start to rise
again if it doesn't and there's
certainly a chance maybe there's two out
of two or three out of ten that it won't
happen if that turnout doesn't start to
rise then you have to say the United
States is in some trouble I only have a
short time left are you getting tired of
all this I sometimes have the feeling
and I've said this to people that have
the horrible feeling it it's like going
into a movie and waiting and this
where I came in but a whole new politics
may be is about to start maybe not maybe
it'll prove something maybe it'll yield
something and maybe it won't maybe this
time the politicians will live up to
expectations but if they really do it'll
be a first normally what you get out of
American politics is these short bursts
of real creativity and coalition change
and then it sort of settles into a norm
I think we've had a lower norm than
usual I hope there's a real change
coming the name of the book is politics
of rich and poor wealth and the American
electorate and the Reagan aftermath our
guest for the last hour has been Kevin
Phillips Thank You mr. Phillips
thank you